esta vez aquí tenemos una cartera y
vamos a ver de qué está hecha y cómo
funciona así que este es el porta café o
la jarra am o como sea que lo que a
llamar está hecha de vidrio y bueno la
manera en la que está hecho este vidrio
creo es que se calientan y después se
funde dentro del molde y después deje
enfriar y seguramente debe de haber un
dispositivo mecánico que haga la forma
para este pico ahora tenemos esta banda
de acero inoxidable la cual envuelve al
molde y es moldeada en el vidrio este
este de aquí es la asa el cual parece
estar hecho de polipropileno es decir de
un plástico de bajo costo y si te das
cuenta éste no tiene textura o algo
lujoso de hecho hasta se puede sentir la
cultura del molde porque es una asa de
muy bajo costo y también puedes ver esta
parte de aquí que puede salirse de un
golpe y se encaja presión está payasada
de polipropileno y bueno todo se
mantiene junto gracias
a esta pieza de acero inoxidable que
hace muy buen trabajo creo que
probablemente podemos desmontar esta
tapa y ver qué hay dentro de ella así
que voy a necesitar un desarmador
este que va a ser un poco más corto para
poder desmontar esto y ver qué es lo que
tira dentro
y bueno creo que esto no está diseñado
para desmontar sé pero pero lo vamos a
intentar
y tal vez esto no está diseñado para
venir aparte así que tal vez no tengamos
mucha suerte y no lo está esto cierra
presión de lujo pero puedes ver que ya
tenemos dos partes que están moldeadas
por separado y que son dos piezas
diferentes y bueno veamos
vamos a retirar este tornillo para
mostrarles cómo va todo junto
bien
bien aquí está
guau algo voto por aquí y bueno puedes
ver que hay un pequeño soporte que va
por dentro y por donde entra el tornillo
y mantiene esta banda de acero
inoxidable en su lugar y también así es
como la asa está sujetada y en la parte
superior observa aquí tenemos sólo un
pequeño borde que sostiene en la parte
superior del mango una pequeña pieza que
se incorpora el vidrio y se abrocha y
así es como se sostiene todo puedes ver
que estos techos de una sola pieza
moldeada stones mientras que aquí
tenemos otra y aquí otra justo así es
como hacen la asa hay tres diferentes
piezas de plástico moldeado el molde se
junta sim y puedes rotarlo porque puedes
sentir la cultura del molde en el
interior de la asa aunque también se
puede notar por la forma de la asa que
está hecho de tal manera que va a salir
más fácil del molde probablemente sea un
molde de tres partes y haya una tercera
sección que vaya pues nuestra dirección
y bueno ésta también es otra parte
moldeada por inyección
y la cem en tal manera que bueno pueda
encajar justo aquí ahora podemos ver por
acá el acero inoxidable y estoy casi
seguro que pagaron un dinero extra por
esta pieza ya que esta pieza de acero
inoxidable es muy importante que no se
aflojen y probablemente llegue a estar
bastante húmeda y si estuviera hecha de
un acero regular u otro material podría
correrse y posiblemente separarse y
bueno no queremos que suceda eso no
queremos que esté oxidada y mucho menos
cuando tenemos el café caliente así que
por eso tenemos esta pieza de acero
inoxidable y bueno todo esto es la garra
del café ya está así que es buen momento
para pasar a la cafetera así que aquí
tenemos la cafetera y aquí tenemos un
contenedor al interior de la cafetera el
cual es un espacio donde bueno ponemos
el filtro del café y después los granos
del café y por acá llenamos esto con
agua y cerramos la tapa la encendemos y
esperamos y nos da café
y lo que sucede es que esa agua que
ponemos dentro se entrena a través de un
pequeño canal es justo este pequeño hoyo
que tenemos aquí podemos verlo es más lo
voy a apuntar con el desarmador para que
lo veas más fácilmente se va a drenar
por ese hoyo y va hacia la parte de
abajo así que vamos a ver la parte de
abajo y vamos a ver qué sucede ahí
ahora para eso modifique este desarmador
que estoy usando el cual es un
desarmador económico de 99 centavos de
dólar
así que modifique la punta para poder
quitar los tornillos de seguridad es muy
importante que no hagas esto en casa a
menos que tengas un profesional que esté
contigo porque esto no está diseñado
para retirarse y es justo por esta razón
que se usan estos tornillos que tienen
una cabeza especial para que no se
retiren pero lo que quiero es mostrarles
que hay adentro así que aquí vamos de
nuevo todo esto es una parte moldeada
por inyección parece ser una parte como
el de adán lo que significa que hay dos
materiales diferentes que son moldeados
juntos
veamos si puedo sacar este tornillo
creo que no se quiere quedar pero no
importa vamos a seguir sin él este
material de aquí estas bases están
hechas de un material más suave y este
material también es polipropileno es
plástico recuerda un plástico de bajo
costo los moldes se juntan y la
inyección moldea este material y una vez
que este material comienza a endurecerse
entonces moldean por inyección el
material más suave eso es con moldeado o
un moldeado doble y bueno puedes pensar
en otras cosas que están hechas así por
ejemplo algunas veces los cepillos de
dientes tienen unas cerdas suaves al
centro y por otra parte tienes la parte
más dura del cepillo de dientes así que
ambas partes son moldeadas en un solo
molde un molde de doble inyección en
todo caso esta es la parte de abajo y
esto permite que el aire entra en la
cámara del calentador para ventilar un
poco el calor de aquí y bueno por acá
está el calentador aquí es donde la
magia ocurre el agua baja por ese tubo y
da vuelta por esta forma en herradura y
después sube por aquí lo que causa que
el agua suba de nuevo
a través de este tubo hasta este otro
tubo de kim y llegue a este aparato y
por último se drene a través de estos
hoyos y cae aquí adentro esto de aquí es
sobre una pieza de plástico que causa
que esta parte se alinean junto con la
parte superior cuando las sierras así el
agua se lo suben se drena y cae sobre
los grandes del café y después sale el
café por lo tanto el calentador hace dos
cosas primero que el agua suba por este
tubo se expanda y golpee en la cafetera
problemas calienta esta placa de aquí y
la manera en la que lo hace es usando el
material llamado cable de micrófono el
cual es una aleación de níquel y cromo
que se calienta fácilmente y es una
buena resistencia cuando se calienta el
aluminio es también un excelente
conductor del calor conduce el calor muy
bien y lo lleva a la bandeja que
calienta el agua que cae acá adentro
para esto hay numerosos mecanismos de
seguridad dentro de esta cafetera aquí
puedes ver que tenemos dos fusibles
térmicos y si están muy calientes
estallan
y previenen que siga incrementando el
calor también hay un sensor de
temperatura que esto puede apagar la
cafetera si se pone muy caliente de
hecho creo que lo que trae dentro es una
lámina metálica
esta es una lámina que tiene un bajo
coeficiente de expansión térmica como el
link bar el cual es una aleación que no
se expande demasiado con el calor y
puede ser aliado con otros metales no sé
como el cobre que se expande bastante
con el calor y lo que sucede es que
cuando esos dos metales están cerca uno
del otro el inverno se expande demasiado
pero el otro material sí y provoca que
la lámina metálica se doble
así cuando se doblan si está conduciendo
la electricidad se aleja del contacto
así que pensemos que este es el contacto
y entonces se aleja del contacto cuando
la temperatura es muy alta entonces
ellos eligen las piezas pri metálicas
las calibran basándose en cuanto a
temperatura va a recibir
usando el tamaño del metal la cantidad
de metal y los tipos de metales
basándose en la temperatura que quieren
que la cafetera
no quisiera que llegue no sé a 500
grados o algo cercano a eso entonces hay
probablemente una temperatura que eligen
y así seleccionan la lámina bimetálica
de tal manera que reaccionen a esa
temperatura y corte el circuito y es así
como pienso que ese sensor de
temperatura funciona
bien ahora vamos a seguir adelante y
desmontar el resto
esta pieza de aquí es algo genial es una
pequeña barra que mantiene el calentador
en su lugar y esta pequeña barra tiene
esos tornillos los cuales tienen estas
pequeñas arandelas curiosas en ellos y
las arandelas están hechas de un
material fibroso que no conduce el calor
muy bien y esto es muy útil porque no
quisieras que los tornillos conduzcan el
calor al plástico y es que imagínate si
conducen el calor al plástico el
plástico se ablanda
o se deforma e incluso puede derretirse
así que no queremos que eso ocurra y por
eso se aísla es la parte del calor muy
bien así que vamos a seguir quitando
estos tornillos de aquí todos estos
tornillos están fijados en algo llamado
tornillo de refuerzo que es una pieza de
plástico sobresaliente al interior que
mantiene el tornillo en su lugar y
porque pueden ver que el calentador está
sujetado por esta pasta la cual es
llamada pasta térmica y ayuda a que el
calor se transmita de esta horquilla en
forma de herradura a la bandeja de acero
donde se pone la cara
ahora vamos a retirar esos tornillos de
aquí esos tornillos sostienen el cable
del enchufe en su lugar y observen que
el cable está enlazado alrededor de sí
mismo y esto es para que no puedas sacar
el cable de la cafetera y esto es muy
importante porque no quisieras soltar
ningún cable porque si tienes algún
cable suelto potencialmente esa sería la
causa de un incendio o de un
cortocircuito así que es mejor
prevenirlo no queremos eso y es justo
por ello que este lazo nos ayuda a
prevenirlo ahora bien si bajamos un poco
por aquí creo que podemos retirar esta
parte
estamos desmontando las dos mitades de
la cafetera y no sé si puedan ver bien
al interior pero ahí abajo hay un
pequeño símbolo que dice pepe y eso
significa polipropileno así que ahora sí
podemos afirmar qué tipo de plástico es
este
el polipropileno es un plástico muy
económico que es ampliamente usado en
productos comerciales es uno de los
plásticos más económicos lo usan en todo
desde lavavajillas tinas cafeteras hasta
secadores de cabello
en cualquier caso trataré de sacar ese
tornillo que está muy ajustado pueden
ver qué bueno voy a separar las dos
mitades y veamos si poder desmontar esto
para que lo vean
bien aquí tenemos un tornillo más
bien ya con esto pueden ver así como las
dos mitades la cafetera se unen se unen
de esta manera y bueno el grupo de
tornillos de refuerzo de aquí se alinean
con los agujeros de este lado y así
puedes presionar las dos piezas juntas
estas dos mitades son moldeadas por
dirección los moldes se unen así y así y
las dos partes se juntan y son capaces
de crear esta forma y pueden ver que el
agua entre por este tubo de kim se
calienta y sube por este otro tubo de
aquí
ahora por aquí por aquí este es el
anillo el cual
si lo movemos entra justo por aquí y
esta es la placa metálica donde se
coloca el calentador la placa se coloca
dentro del anillo y así se tiene un
acabado agradable y bueno creo que creo
que eso es todo acerca de una cafetera
así es como funciona y de lo que está
hecho así que espero que lo hayan
disfrutado